you know one of the things about a cult
is that the cult leader will expect if
not demand
absolute and total sacrifice and loyalty
from the cult followers and failed
Arizona Republican gubernatorial
candidate Kerry lake is doing exactly
that she wants supporters who are
willing to go to jail for her the
delusions of grandeur are getting worse
and worse for Kerry Lake here she is
saying these listen you should be
willing to go and sit in jail that for
the movement or whatever but really she
means for her check this out I wish that
somebody would say you know what arrest
me then I don't care we need people with
courage to say class what Felony go
ahead go for it arrest me because this
is a botched election and you're
disenfranchising tell me it's a felony
to be out here doing what I'm doing and
arrest me because Kerry Lake really won
even though she didn't folks in Mojave
County when you allow this kind of an
election in Maricopa County to stand
yeah I like this clip because it
confirms very openly and clearly what
we've suspected for a long time which is
that this is a cult you're willing to go
to jail for me right because I'm that
important to you has she offered them a
pardon on state charges when she's
installed as Governor as Donald Trump
demanded that she be on Troth Central in
the middle of the night earlier this
week like if she's really that confident
she's ultimately going to overturn this
why not make that offer when I finally
Ascend to the governorship I'm going to
Pardon every single one of you truly a
person with not a single redeeming
quality about her Carrie Lake she also
by the way did the globalist thing
and it's so tired at this point but here
she pulls that out as well saying it's
bigger than her that and this this is
another cult thing
even though I need you to go to jail for
me it's really bigger than me in this
case it's about the globalists we feel
very confident in our case and I have
not given up one centilla of the fight I
have in me somebody said Carrie you're
fearless and I said you know I guess I'm
I'm fearless right now in this difficult
time because what I fear most of all is
what happens if we don't step forward
and act with courage right now what
we're left with we will have a shell of
our country we look at what's happening
in Brazil and what's happening in China
we'll be looking a lot like China and
I'm not talking about the protests
happening now I'm talking about we'll be
enslaved by globalist system if we don't
stand up right now this is our moment
this is our true moment right now in our
history Now understand that if you went
to Kerry Lake and said what exactly do
you mean by globalism and what are the
parameters of the globalist system
she probably couldn't answer maybe she'd
come up with some passing thing but she
wouldn't be able to really answer if you
go to Cary Lake supporters and many of
them are Trump supporters as well and
you ask them what is globalism what do
you what do you mean what by when you
talk about globalism and globalists if
you're lucky
they'll be able to Rattle off the names
of a few Jewish men
but they are not even understanding what
it is that is being fed to them so
reminder Kerry Lake didn't win Kerry
Lake will not be the governor of Arizona
don't send her any money if you want to
you know fool in their money or soon
parted it's all a scam she's she didn't
win and she's not going to be the
governor but now she's saying this is
about fighting globalists and you should
be willing to go to jail for me it is a
cult ladies and gentlemen as many of you
know I am fascinated by cons and scams
and multi-level marketing and all of
this different stuff I recently saw
Inside the Mind of a con artist on
curiosity stream it's six episodes and
it was excellent I don't think I would
have discovered it were it not for our
sponsor curiosity stream curiosity
stream has all the newest and best
documentary films they've got the big
titles from the well-known filmmakers
they've got valuable Independent films
tons of original content that you can't
find anywhere else when I'm at home
browsing my different streaming
platforms I find curiosity stream to
really have the best selection of
documentaries specifically because
documentaries is all that they have and
they're always adding new titles my
audience gets access to curiosity
streams entire library of documentaries
for just 15 bucks a year that's 25 off
go to
curiositystream.com Pacman or use the
code Pacman the link is down below